one Batman take three Margaret wow this
place - really something great right yes
cerebral allows me to connect with every
mutant on the planet I'm think about
making like a mutant dating app like
mutant mingle or odd yeah something that
rhymes with tender but not war doesn't
work well hey I know you should connect
with don't say it you know who I'm
talking huh I know who you're talking
about that's what I'm saying don't say
it thank you
mutant girl that you met at the bar no
way you're not in don't you want the
claw right in dg2 not want to do that
you could tell she was thinking that she
did not want to claw right into me how
do you know she was you think because I
know she wasn't thinking that that's my
power I hear what women think I'm like
Mel Gibson and that Mel Gibson movie
that the women don't women what women
want what women want that is me I am a
90s disabled bald Mel Gibson well can
you use cerebro to find some other hot
mutant [ __ ] hell yeah let's do it
alright that's what I'm talking about
Isis the bad guys we're all knocked out
cold so I you should be good to go I'll
have a good night doing your whole
spider thing alright
hey this might sound like a weird
question but I don't worry about it lay
it on me what do you got they think that
maybe we should kiss oh hi I'm not into
dudes Oh trust me I know I mean eating
right I'm just saying it's raining out
he's raining out the linings very mood
moody in a good way and you did just
save yeah I look good doing it more
spider-man my crop buddy let's do this
[Music]
I can't go sorry I need a little help
and do is just get to be us I love that
never start with the head alright you
want to be Here I am I want to see what
you do when you didnt dissapoint cut the
[ __ ] where's dad you want to know I
got my scores my father loves a bringer
oh man he got oh man alright you're got
poor are you crying yeah maybe a little
bit it's the whole father thing sort of
get me of my parents situations you know
whining about that oh yeah you're right
I'm sorry you should be really easy for
a nine-year-old to deal with the murder
of his parents right in front of him in
the middle of a book at 25 years ago
what are you 34 37 which is the
perfectly appropriate day should be
crying about your parents I tell you and
people like this sensitive side of oh is
that right women love it so you're
saying the fact that your parents are
dead helps you to get chicks it's
unfortunate that my parents had to die
for me to get chicks but my parents
death helps me get you okay you're sick
you